[Applause]
imagine you walk to the secret
foundation on his sole purpose for
existence is to secure contain and
protect any and all unusual objects of
creatures supernatural extraterrestrial
or otherwise they have hundreds of those
objects some are harmless and safe
whilst others can mutate your body until
machined and dissolve your mind that
they're soulless husk of your former
self still others can cause widespread
paranoia fear anger and hallucinations
there are even a few that can cause the
earth itself to shatter and tear million
shards of rock and tell All Humans until
you're dead the secret foundation holds
them all in containment to protect the
billions of souls resting on earth and
imagine your task was studying analyzing
and defending those objects all without
getting you your colleagues of civilians
killed no pressure right well that's
what I did they an and they're putting
myself in danger for Humanity
it may seem dangerous and I was but it
was fun well-paid and I worked with some
of the most badass people you could ever
licked emphasis on the past tense sadly
now imagine something different imagine
if the specimens were all Unleashed
every single one and one day millions
would die from the chaos that would
ensue unless other millions would be
transformed that the grotesque creatures
the likes of which the world has not
seen for centuries the hundreds of
thousands who survived would find
themselves in a world completely
distorted an undistinguished from the
bright green and blue world they had
just experienced a day ago now you're
starting to realize something on you
this isn't hypothetical after all you're
living the nightmare and it's all
because of us because of our failing us
you know her as know a few survival
sites mainly a secured military sites or
small farm stares around the world some
have even managed to take of our old
foundation sites they're safe for now
but with all the objects either causing
chaos or destroyed I've been sitting
here at site 23 alone
hell no harm in revealing what I am it's
not like anyone who wants me dead wonder
what site 23 actually is I'm rambling
night okay I wouldn't be surprised I
think I may may be starting to go a
little crazy these logs are the only
things that keep me sane sane sanity so
funny walk that I know I'm losing my
grip my own salad thing coherence I've
done a decade of self-imposed exile or
quarantine whichever makes more sense
anyway if you're listening to this I'm
probably dead I only took me five years
to die yeah five years five long lundi
years and as well try to give you a
history of what happened to the world
five years ago I can remember that's the
thing lord I don't remember what
happened I spent every waking moment
trying to figure out how every single
artifact or contained creature escaped
to destroy the world no reason makes
sense was an inside job I can tame and
preach war catastrophic failure of
safety systems and the nucleus there
must have been some combination of the
reasons but
I can't speak for any of the other sites
say 19 so 21 site 7 you know how it
feels to watch the world die of course
you wouldn't
no one would and you'll be lucky you
wouldn't have to see people wrapped
apart by the desert like monstrosity
you wouldn't have to machines in New
York I watched as Washington DC I
watched the entire that's all I was able
to do dr. clef dr. Agathon mates dr.
jack bright dr. Lorenson dr. Simon glass
dr. Hayden dr. aura dr. McKenzie agent
Velma cough mr. Avery Cates dr. winters
dr. light Nadine Sadie that's the last
one probably I think I may be the last
one alive the last one who remembers
what we did when we tried to do for the
world
I don't think this will be kept safe for
nearly long enough but I might as well
try to anyone who finds this know that I
have done my duty I have tried to make
things right from here I will return one
day to make things right I will return
with or without my colleagues I have no
illusions ahead of me
I've almost likely died before I ever
make it back but at least I'll be with
the people I worked whether I do people
who I know I'd feel safer us
so this is a this has been dr. Jacob
Kensington robotics expert and staff
researcher that's i-23 last known
foundation researchers still alive